their fears of new violence in Hong Kong
after the territory's chief executive
invoked emergency powers last used in
the 1950s in response protesters have
begun blocking roads holding umbrellas
and despite the government announcing a
ban on face masks many demonstrators
have been wearing them from midnight
local time they could face up to a year
in jail jail for wearing full or partial
face coverings Carrie Lam says she has
imposed the ban to deter violence
potestas from turning out let's take a
listen to what she said and I would say
that we are now in ruther extensive and
serious public danger it is essential
for us to stop violence and restore
calmness in society as soon as possible
we hope that the new legislation can
help us to achieve this objective now
Dee Jarvis Phoebe a congas following the
story first and joins us from Hong Kong
Phoebe very strong words from Carrie Lam
day but a serious public danger the
territory is facing what's been the
response among protesters to this
emergency legislation
well we have talked to some of the
protesters about their response to these
tough law that some of them they told me
that Ashley this measure will deter
those relatively peaceful protesters
from taking to streets because they fear
the white the white terror now in the
city but but on the contrary for the
violent protesters who are the target of
the government some of the radical
protesters actually told me that this is
not going to deter for them from taking
any violence act or are going on the
streets anymore that they are not going
to stop their actions that just because
of this law because for them it's not a
big deal for them to evaluate another
piece of law so whether this will be
like and really a very effective measure
to stop the violence
claimed by the government government is
still in doubt and some of the activists
they also submit judicial review to the
court already to challenge the
government's decision because they think
this is unconstitutional that inmate
violates the our city minute
Constitution and also the human rights
law in Hong Kong so some of they want to
stop the enactment of the law by legal
means so some of them have taken this
matter to the court but how is police
meanwhile going to enforce the ban on
face masks because as we heard some
people are defying this ban and still
wearing masks
well this law not only to ban people
from wearing masks but also to crown
greater power to the police to conduct
searching like underneath under the new
law or the police can search any one and
they can require anyone to remove their
masks like during searching so if anyone
refused the request of the police now so
it will be considered as breaking the
law and they will face prison sentence
for up to six months so this is not a
law not only going to affect those are
participate in public assemblies but
literally any way and anyone with masks
that refuse to comply with the request
of the police will be with the
authorities taking such a strong line
now not just against protesters as you
said is there a fear that this could
lead to clashes and violence yeah I will
say beyond doubt there will be clashes
for the rest of the day because as you
have mentioned earlier in the report we
can see protesters already there
gathering I like on the streets I before
the end of the press conference of the
government so there are more assemblies
are called online to be taking part in
various districts in regions across Hong
Kong tonight so we expect that the
turnout of these protests will be huge
tonight because people will like come
out to express their anger towards this
law like especially before midnight when
before the law comes into effect at
midnight so very likely that there will
be serious confrontation with the police
right Phoebe Kong in Hong Kong thank you
very much for the update on the tense
situation there